each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available all right well welcome thanks
for uh the few of you in here in person
and um those of you online on reset uh
it's a great privilege honor to be able
to introduce and host um Dr Milan TBE
from University of Southern California
uh thankfully he has his title up here
on uh on the slide because he has quite
possibly the longest um Professor
professorial title um in the USC system
for sure he's the Helen n and EMT H
Jones professor in engineering and um
one of the I'm not going to run through
his long list of um accomplishments but
what strikes me from his bio is the
number of awards that he's won just in
raw total but also the diversity of um
domains that he's won them in everything
from engineering research to community
service um societal impact and and also
teaching which is um awards that uh
professors um rarely get but should be
rightfully uh honored when they do so um
so Dr Tay has had a long and illustrious
career primarily in the world of
security games and and Game Theory is
applied to security games he's worked
with all sorts of um government agencies
municipalities um to help make ports
oceans cities safer um but recently and
the reason I was really excited to um
have him here at Microsoft research is
his thinking around green security game
so the way that we can take Game Theory
and traditional security game approaches
and start thinking about how we can
deploy people in the real world to help
protect natural resources whether that's
Fisheries wildlife
forestry things like that so that's
going to be the topic of millan's talk
today and I'm looking forward to hearing
what he has to say great well thank you
uh thank you for people who are here and
people who may be watching online but
we'll keep this informal uh and so
please feel free to interrupt me and we
have what up about till 11:30 something
like that okay
so the work I'm going to describe uh
overall uh security games is a joint
work with the number of current and
former PhD students and post talks and
uh two of them current students are here
Fay Fang I'm showing her over here and
thine win so this is uh a picture of our
current group
so um I'm going to jump right into the
topic which is uh security so we know
that we Face uh globally challenges of
security for protecting our ports and
airports interdicting the illegal flow
of drugs weapons and money suppressing
Urban
Crime now in all of these cases uh we
have limited security resources and how
to optimize the use of limited resources
something that we've buil been building
decision aids for for um security
agencies more recently we've been U
taking some of these techniques and
applying them for security of uh Forest
fish and wildlife and this is what we've
been referring to as green
security so the commonality in all of
these domains in all of these challenges
is that we have limited resources lot of
things to protect and a watchful
adversary who can monitor our defenses
and exploit any patterns so how do you
schedule or plan or allocate limited
resources taking into account this
watchful adversary and we've been
appealing to game the and in particular
this notion of stackelberg security
games and so in this talk I will briefly
introduce stackelberg security games all
then start talking about infrastructure
security this is mainly to give a
introduction to some of the work that
we've done in the past and so the first
10 minutes for stackle workg security
games uh next 5 minutes or so for
infrastructure security and the bulk of
the talk will be focused on introducing
green security this is a exciting um and
important area for research I'll F I'll
outline some of the applications as well
as some of the challenges we face and
then finally um pause which is a
protection assistant for wildlife
security a decision Aid that we've been
building and um so I know Fay and thine
who are here have heard this talk like a
100 times before and so you know if you
want to check check your email or
something that's fine but hopefully
you'll be able to answer questions from
uh the audience that is here so Lucas we
were talking yesterday about um triple
Ai and NY papers and all these sort of I
went back and checked how many papers on
security games we've published just uh
as our own group and so depending on how
you count so there's like 60 to 70
papers over the last 8 years insecurity
games and so um I'm going to give
highlights of some of this green
security is a very new topic for us and
we haven't published as much though so
um let's begin by talking about
stackelberg security games and so I'm
going to introduce this game using a 2X
two example where we have the US Coast
Guard trying to protect a toy Port of
two targets targets one and two target
one happens to be more important than
Target Two If as a result the Coast
Guard are always at Target one an
adversary conducting service
surveillance will attack Target Two the
adversary gets a positive reward of one
the Coast Guard get a negative reward
minus one if as a result the Coast Guard
ver to switch and always protect Target
two now an adversary conducting
surveillance will attack Target one the
adversary again gets a positive reward
five the Coast Guard again get a
negative reward
minus5 so any deterministic strategy an
adversary could defeat if the Coast
Guard were to use a mixed strategy a
randomized strategy so that's 60% of the
time they're at Target 1 and 40% of the
time they're at Target Two an adversary
conducting surveillance will only know
that the Coast Guard are here 60% there
40% but what they will do tomorrow
remains
unpredictable the goal here is to come
up with a mixed strategy a randomized
policy that increases the cost and
uncertainty to an attacker in coming up
with a plan of
attack we are not guaranteeing a 100%
security because there is no such thing
in the real world we are optimizing the
use of our limited security resources
now these kinds of games are called
stackle BG games because security
resources commit first Defenders commit
first the adversary observes and then
responds um what we are looking for is a
stackelberg equilibrium for a 2X two
game we can solve this by hand you know
should it be a 6040 allocation should it
be a 7030 allocation but when there are
trillions of possible Patrol strategies
and a large number of targets solving
these problems by hand becomes difficult
and that's where our research comes in
so research has been in uh solving
massive scale games under uncertainty
and this has led to a number of
applications on infrastructure security
so work uh I guess is in use uh for
infrastructure security for example uh
by the US Coast Guard in generating
Patrols in ports such as Boston and New
York and Los
Angeles as well as um generating patrols
around the Staten Island Ferry in all of
these cases a stackle BG game
formulation is used to generate these
strategies our work is also used by the
TSA to assign Air Marshals to flights on
a randomized basis so again using a
stackle BG game model to generate these
uh mixed strategies all of this work
started by earlier work at the LA
airport where the idea was generating
randomized Patrol set on terminals or
checkpoints our work has also been
tested by the LA Sheriff's department
and this is for um trying to suppress
crime on
trains
so this was the past work which I will
not uh focus on much today where we are
going with this is uh green security and
so you've arrived at exactly the right
time area so
I know old
work
so um here with green security we are
focused on protection of forest fish and
wildlife for example with the Coast
Guard our focus is generating patrols uh
in the Gulf of Mexico to try to deter
illegal
fishing uh with IBM it is for cleaner
rivers in India this is for inspections
of factories that pollute water um with
panthera and WWF and so these are two
ngls and that'll be primarily the focus
of my talk today it's for generating
optimally generating patrols based on
past poaching data and so forth to
protect endangered species what's new
here is the fact that there is a a large
amount of adversary Behavior data
unfortunately there's a lot of poaching
a lot of illegal fishing which provides
us the data on the basis of which we can
learn adversary models and this then
becomes a repeated game we can learn
these models to improve our game playing
strategies and when they attack again we
can continually improve our strategies
here we are um also able to incorporate
or need to incorporate uh insights from
conservation biology and so have uh
collaboration from somebody like Lucas
or other conservation biologists uh
would be very valuable or is very
valuable and so similar L for
criminology in fact there's a conference
that we've been organizing C4 conference
for conservation criminology and
computation which tries to bring
together these interdisciplinary
insights there is a a newer domain that
we've also worked on which is uh urban
crime and here there is a lot of data so
this is area around USC for example
where the problem is more lowlevel crime
as in people stealing laptops and cell
phones and so on here we can start with
a clean slate and learn an adversary
model from scratch from data because
there's a lot of data people report
crime so we have um infrastructure
security games where we have fortunately
limited numbers of attacks and data
where we have to rely more on Expert
knowledge to Green security where there
is medium amount of data let's say
because we have
silent victim problems animals are not
calling in saying there's poaching
attacks going on and so this leads to
some fundamental challenges in the fact
that data are biased the fact that we
have to have a trade-off in Exploration
and exploitation and opportunistic crime
then of course extends it to situations
where there's a lot more data more
recently I guess U us and I'm sure
others too face a lot of pressure from
funding agencies to move all these
techniques toward cyber security and so
that's one of the newer areas of
research so this uh gives a overview of
the work that we've been doing in this
area of security games it's a highly
interdisciplinary space USC was uh kind
enough to do a magazine article on our
work outlining um and one of the things
it produced was this map outlining all
the places where our work is deployed
and particularly with the use of uh with
the collaboration of non-governmental
organization you can see that some of
this work now is getting deployed
outside the US and some of our
collaborators are deploying this work in
other parts of the world as
well armor and it's many
iterations and uh but this is only
possible because of uh the
interdisciplinary collaboration with the
law enforcement agency so we've really
had to embed ourselves um you know Fay
and thine and everybody else have gone
trying to understand problems locally
and then based on that try to use embed
those constraints in the solutions along
the way for example theyve had to learn
new kinds of cutting plane algorithms
that they didn't imagine they would
learn as part of their computer science
training you comment a little bit about
about domain spec specificity in terms
of the learnings and the intensity of
effort versus the general principles
that you rely upon that you can share
among the applications yes uh so I
mean so I mean we are very much focused
on this uh use inspired research and so
there are so many instances where the
domain provides us a new kind of a
problem and then it generalizes to many
other domains but when you encounter
that do that kind of a domain for the
first time it throws open a completely
new type of a problem that we had
encountered before and then you
generalize so it's very much the I mean
we like to think of it very much the
classic use inspired research uh where
you start from a problem you find a you
try to find a solution and in that you
recognize a general principle that
applies to many other domains but that
also solves the problem at hand not
everything is like that clearly
sometimes it's just the problem that
works in this in this domain but uh this
is been a repeated uh occurrence and
there are sometimes theorems that people
are able to prove that would be
wonderful if only the domain constraints
could just go away um so for example uh
you know here's a theorem that would
apply it would speed up all our
computation if the Air Marshals would
only have even number even numbered
cycles that is to say uh they would not
intervene in
hijacking on on odd cycled flights or
something like that so you know if okay
returning from going to from New
York r
solution and so um so so it's it's it's
it's very interesting I think uh We've
we've learned a lot in terms of really
understanding that the domain really
constrains the solution space and the
problem
space so to put all our cards on the
table we also have a startup armor way
that um has you know now run by several
of my former PhD students and it's
growing things are U you know there's a
lot of EXC it's a very exciting time in
terms of where all of this research and
applications are
going something to another domain just
before you move on to to the green um
staying non green for a little bit um
looked at fishing attacks and some of
the online cyber security issues from
the point of view of your methods so you
know while you're
here to meet with some of the fishing
experts and so on I not the wildlife
fishing yes I would really I would
really love to do that I would be really
really uh formulated as a cial yes this
so I haven't done it but my uh one of my
former post or two of my former post dos
actually you know they've formulated
some of these problems in this framework
and they're going after these problems
uh I mean I would love to I would love
to really go go after this
because yes so I was going to see well
yeah spased on your schedule you can
meet some of these folks that do this
kind of I I would love to do that I
would be we have actually as I was
saying we've getting pushed uh to say
you got to move to cyber if you want
more funding essentially in some of
these cases and so that's the way it's
been working and so that's uh well but
of course opposed to going there for
because that's where the interest is if
it really we can formulate those
challenges in a way that would make
sense for the that's right so I think I
mean obviously we are interested in the
fundamental algorithmic advances that we
can make we are interested in the
domains as well but you know hopefully
what we will find is that the principles
will apply please C can I just get a
little context and I apologize if this
came up already but it seems to me that
um this whole model is dependent on kind
of the stupidity of your adversaries
right it's in their interest to be as
random as possible within their their
domain and if they're random then you
can't do anything better than be rather
no no no no so so I think um uh so the
way I explained it in the beginning is
that we are assuming the adversary is
actually very in early part of this work
is that the adversary is rational they
are very observant they know exactly
the uh patrolling strategies the mixed
strategies that you're playing and then
they choose from their perspective
what's in their best interest to attack
and so they are just picking so it's
like uh uh I mean they what what we are
doing is we are playing some kind of
randomized strategy they are observing
where what you're doing and they'll pick
that one spot which is the best for them
which happens usually to be the worst
for us and so that's the way the game
gets played so they're not playing a
randomized strategy isn't for both to be
random here no in the stackle BG game uh
the defender plays a mixed strategy and
the adversary's pure strategy response
is optimal so the adversary's job is
really very simple in this model which
is look at the you know look at the
patrolling strategy of the defender and
find that one place where you can attack
and get the best uh possible result for
yourself and so it's a fairly different
model compared to a simultaneous move
game model the computational complexity
here is polinomial time compared to so
there so there's a unique equilibrium as
opposed to having you know to worry
about multiple equilibria so this model
offers some advant advantages over the
normal sort of simultaneous move game
Nash equilibrium type
solution going to this domain of
airports and airport security um we can
Define the problem in the scope of the
LAX airport but you know for a terrorist
point of view it's actually a bigger
game right if LAX is really well
protected you can Target another Airport
have you looked into this kind of
interaction
between these agency
how making one thing more secure May
deviate to another one right right right
so I mean I I completely agree that um
uh you know that really there is a
bigger game that is being played I mean
we've thought about it uh on a on a
national scale how would you go about
doing these things uh it's not something
that we've had access to in terms of
saying here you know our algorithms are
actually deployed on a national scale
for all of the airports or something
like that what so that's something that
would be interesting to do there's no um
opposition from us to to think about it
in that way but it's just something that
hasn't been given to us as a problem to
think
about so um let me move on to
infrastructure uh security and I know
that uh I mean it's great we are having
an interactive session so I'll try to
just speed things along a little bit
because I I do have a lot to cover you
have to you have to until noon right so
oh okay that's good that's
that's that's good that's good we're
just going to keep you here all day
that's that's fine too that's fine too
uh so I guess the longest lecture I've
given is 9 hours uh so it's this was a
summer ich gu summer school in Beijing
they kept us for 9 hours each so morning
9 evening
6 lecture
that's true that's true that's
true um so let me start with
infrastructure uh security so here uh
I'll just highlight one piece of work
that we've done just to give you a
flavor for how this work gets done is
protect which is we've built for the US
Coast Guard protect is an acronym of the
system so you can see we spend a lot of
time trying to come up with good
acronyms so this is a decision Aid built
for the Coast Guard to generate
randomized Patrols in ports taking into
account the values of different targets
and it's deployed in Boston and New York
and Los Angeles and maybe going towards
other ports in the country as well what
the Coast Guard are worried about are
attacks of this type but also less
serious attacks that might happen um in
2011 the system initially was deployed
in Boston at which point they made a
nice video for us after they uh
evaluated the implementation to be a
success and they have some criteria for
how they evaluated it they made a nice
video I'll play a 30-second clip from
that
video more focused upon providing
effective presence reducing
predictability and enhancing the Safety
and Security within our ports protect
guided patrols became a source of Pride
for Station Boston Crews and it doesn't
get much better than that protect has
also had other positive side effects
such as the development of better
tactics techniques and procedures the
results have been exceptional we and so
um beyond the first application for Port
patrols was uh generating patrols around
the Staten Island Ferry and this is uh
work of fang as part of her PhD thesis
and so carrying 60,000 passengers a day
the threat is somebody ramming a boat
into the ferry so the Coast Guard run
these patrols around the ferry these are
actually our algorithms at work uh
actually part of phase the thesis and so
it has completely and radically changed
how they used to run these patrols
before and so sometimes when uh you know
public appreciates uh the patrols and so
forth it's good for the Coast Guard and
also good for us I'm going to explain
how we generate these patrols just to
give a flavor for how this works there's
a discrete SpaceTime representation that
I'm going to use there's actually a
continuous time version of this which is
published in the Journal of AI research
2013 but I'll use the discrete SpaceTime
version because it's easier to explain
in the time that we have available so
here we have three locations ABC and
three time points 5 10 and 15 minutes
and we have this Ferry which is jumping
from C at 5 minutes to B at 10 minutes
to a at 15 minutes each of these Red Box
locations are places where an adversary
could attack to protect this Ferry we
can run different patrols we can run a
green Patrol going from B at 5 minutes
to C at 10 minutes to B at 15 minutes
for example a patrol boat can protect
the ferry right next to it as shown by
the red arrow so now we can try to run a
Minimax algorithm a this is a linear
program that just tries to minimize the
adversary's maximum expected utility
by generating probabilities of each of
the r roots that we have and so we can
solve this problem we can get a solution
which gives a probability distribution
over all of the different Roots so it's
saying well probability of brown root is
.17 green is .13 etc etc this could work
but there are n to the power T variables
here n being the number of locations T
being the total number of time slices
because there are exponential numbers of
Patrol routes if you look at it this
way in these Solutions do you make the
assumption that um the the sensing
action is not
observable um by the adversary in other
words um if if if let's say preparation
to sense was observable and therefore an
adversary with continual monitoring
ability could make a could make
decisions based on the ability to sense
prep to sense by the by The Protector
would that disrupt the the the intent of
the algorithm so the algorithm's intent
is um that that I guess the assumption
is that the adversary has complete
knowledge of the overall probabilities
of patrols uh so they have passed
surveillance they have done all of this
they know generally how these you know
how your Patrol probabilities work they
have complete information about exact
but what they don't have is online
information saying right now where is
your Patrol boat right I guess um if
each to char
Ariz the the real world Centric
assumptions that are made in terms of uh
adversaries information gathering
ability in terms of the details of
forting versus executing an attack in
light of the the Dynamics of preparation
and temporal properties of the
protection where to imagine that the
adversary could could do online
observations
of some aspects of what it takes to do
you know nothing's aneous right so there
a tempal progression of a protection
action and so how that would so the so
the idea here is um not so much so we
are not trying to disrupt the adversary
online by observing where the adversary
is at this point in time what we are
trying adversary has the ability to to
observe temporal
aspects of of like say the protecting
Coast Guard boat coming out of its
garage and where it's housed in starting
out to do the surveillance and they can
just watch continually that that action
and wait till that doesn't happen before
they engage their attack given that it's
not we're talking about about Windows of
time intervals Preparatory phases and so
whenever I see this kind of solution I
always wonder
about the richness of the real world
giving adversaries all sorts of Rich
surfaces to attack
that th the the the assumptions of
analytical approach even though it's
beautiful in terms of how right so I
guess the the the I mean that's that's a
great question and something that you
know we repeat always have to ask all so
the basic assumption here is that we are
optimizing limited resources and the
Assumption also is that the ad has
perfect information about your
probabilities of patrols beforehand uh
but online that they they right yeah so
they they have plan so the idea is
something like this that the they are
observing everything they have perfect
knowledge and they're going to plan an
attack at a certain time certain place
because it's not something that they can
sort of uh do a dynamic planning on
that's the that whatever they do they
have to sort of plan and they can't
abort easily you know so that they
actually plan and they
commit right ahead of time that it's can
happen on 911 at 9:13 a.m. on this plane
and so they have the same problems we do
with like you know committing to a tug
book going out at time te and and if I
mean if obviously if they abort their
attack that's good but if uh you but
they abort it every single time at low
cost and it's just wait till real in
online world so so the online thing is
the more interesting aspect which is
what uh you know more recent papers have
started to go after to say okay if you
now allow the adversary to have some
online sensing can you improve your
plans and so that's something also we've
been uh thinking about and modifying it
uh but at some
point yes yes I mean if you if you allow
for the adversary to also have Perfect
online sense because here we are saying
well the adversary has perfect offline
sensing if you now say well they also in
addition have no online and and some
resource to expand on uh monitoring and
ab boarding so the so if you allow for
some partial online it's okay I guess
obviously the trouble becomes if if you
have Perfect online and then and the
instantaneous attack then you're
basically you can't really do anything
then it's a you know so so you need you
need to have iron more iron shield for
your Bo right right so you need you need
the I mean there need to be some
limitations on adversaries capabilities
for us to be able to protect based on
what we have otherwise you know there's
really nothing you can really do um yeah
again don't want to stop to talk and say
it wasn't this a hard problem but if um
many of these situations are of the form
adversary figures
out when stuff is
deployed um and can wait until stuff is
not deployed to do their action without
a lot of planning without a lot of
infrastructure which which Ty I
terrorism you know sort of
lightweight
nasty attacks but I guess that I mean it
depends right I mean if you're thinking
about something that's pre-planned
that's carried out as a as a big attack
then normally uh I mean the the way I've
read incidents and so forth there's
careful planning and it can't be
something where you sort of do it on the
fly
opportunistically your meod might create
pressure to evolve
those right right and and and the more
uh so the idea is right in the beginning
as I said uh you know we we are not
guaranteeing 100% all we are trying to
do is to improve increase the cost and
uncertainty to an attacker and coming up
with a plan of attack so if if we now
put pressure on them that they can't
plan so easily if you know they have to
have much more coordination and all of
this then that's that's what we've
achieved because given limited resources
there's really you cannot not guarantee
100% And so going back to this the main
idea here is that there's exponential
numbers of roots so now if you can focus
on individual segments of these roots
and uh take the probabilities on these
uh you know take the two segments the
green segment and the brown segment
supposing and put it together into a
single probability variable take the
blue uh segments and put that into a
single probability variable now you are
generating probability over these
marginals and uh probability marginal
probability flows and you have n s
multiplied by T variables rather than
the N to the power T variables and we
can now scale up and generate uh the
probabilities that you want by sampling
uh from these marginals directly and so
this is a way in which we can scale up
uh to solve these big problem so this's
one technique there are many other
techniques and I'll if I have time I'll
come to some of these later on so this
is a uh small clip from Southern
California to uh utilize Game Theory as
a way of optimizing and scheduling our
Patrol makes it harder for somebody to
anticipate where the patrols will be so
even though uh we're having to slide
back operations a bit what we're working
on is ideas that we off scheduling that
gives the appearance that we're out
there a lot more than what we are
because it puts the boat in the right
place so this is just uh showing off uh
that you know some of our work has been
mentioned in Congressional testimonies
so we've spent a lot of time obviously
as I mentioned earlier there's a you
know papers at triaa and each and so
forth so they do their normal
evaluations of algorithms and so forth
several of you are very familiar with
that but given that the work is deployed
in the real world it's important for us
to also evaluate how this has performed
in the real world and the focus of our
evaluation there is
does Game Theory lead to an improve
improved performance over how things
used to be done before in terms of
optimizing these limited resources so
we've certainly done evaluations in the
lab to that end bringing in uh human
subjects and simulations we've gone out
in the field and looked at Patrol
quality before and after our system was
deployed or running human versus Game
Theory uh competitions who does a better
job producing unpredictable patrols who
does a better job covering the right
kinds of targets
and shown that game theoretic approaches
have led to better performance and then
to the extent possible field evaluation
against Real adversaries and this
usually is only possible when the
consequences of an attack are low so for
example um we've done tests on LA's
metro rail system looking at Fair
evaders catching fair evaders so once so
this was done over 21 days of Patrol
keeping conditions as identical as
possible on the one side using Game
theoretic approaches on the other side a
humans were given uniform random
approaches but they could interrupt them
and go after Fair evaders wherever they
felt they had the highest chance of
catching fair evaders and shown that if
you look at capture rate per 30 minutes
that the game theoretic schedules led to
a higher rate of capture you
try that that didn't have the human so
so we couldn't because uh essentially
this is real world trials and uh you
know these are these are real officers
doing real tests and there's just no way
to say well you have to exactly follow
this and this only because they know
they can catch more fairy Vaders so they
just said well we are going to go and go
after that happen on the game theory
side you're telling them to follow this
strategy only so we what we tell them is
that even there you can interrupt the
schedule if you don't like what's in
hand and go anywhere you want and and so
what we found is that so actually they
didn't know what was what they just got
a schedule on a phone and they had to F
you know if you don't like it go
somewhere else and catch more fairy
Vaders and right right right right but
it's just that they always interrupted
the uniform random one and they never
interrupted the game theory one and so
that's just the way it was run
everything was kept you they they didn't
know what was what they just had a
schedule on the phone so they didn't
interrupt the game theory they did not
interrupt the game theory always like of
Their Own
right right so we just had you know they
had the schedule on the phone they had
to go and and just you know follow or if
they didn't follow then go somewhere
else and the phone would note wherever
they went and you know caught more fairy
Vaders that that was the whole
experiment and uh it was not possible to
say well you must follow exactly what we
tell you to do
so so this is um this is just what was
done previously and uh originally my
plan was this would get done by 10:50
but that's okay uh we are uh just
slightly off schedule so I'll move on to
Green security games which is the main
topic of today's talk now um so we'll
get as as much as we can get through and
you can tell me when you've had enough
and we can stop there I can go for 9
hours as I mentioned so we'll start with
uh talking about the work we did with
the US Coast Guard so this is um as I
mentioned earlier work with the US Coast
Guard this is generating patrols against
illegal fishing we generated these
patrols um the software is with the
Coast Guard it's under evaluation more
recently we've started working uh for
Forest protection this is with uh
Michigan our colleagues at Michigan
State University and NGO in Madagascar
and the idea here is again trying to
protect Forest uh from illegal logging
another project that's um uh that we're
working on is inspecting factories that
pollute rivers and in particular um
important rivers like the ganga River
and here with IBM the idea is can
we inform the inspectors uh in in you
know using past data and so forth where
to do these randomized inspections but
the work I'll really focus on for
today's talk is the work for protecting
endanger inured Wildlife we have many
collaborations uh around the world one
for example is with the wildlife
conservation Society in
Uganda so this is muchan Falls National
Park in Uganda perhaps some of you have
been there maybe Lucas you've been there
absolutely a wonderful place I was there
last fall um and you know really really
breathtaking in terms of uh animals and
so forth that you see there but there's
threat to the wildlife the picture in
the middle there is a snare so the way
this works is that it opens up and it
buried in the ground and when an animal
steps on it it closes and traps the
animal and then the poacher comes and
kills it we were told that there are
elephants who walk around in the park
with their trunks cut off uh and so
forth because of this to the right are
uh pictures of wire snares there's
thousands of snares and that's just from
2014 um the picture on the left is U me
with with the head of security at the
park so the way they conduct patrols
there is that they'll send out patrols
for some months collect data on Wildlife
on snares that they can find bring all
the data back to headquarters analyze
the data and send out patrols again so
we can cast the problem based on this
inspired by this sort of an idea we've
cast the problem as a repeated stackle
BG game and so you can look at it in
terms of the park in terms of a grid
structure where each grid cell is a
target targets where there's more water
more animals higher weight higher value
and so we are going to start by a
Defender now calculating a randomized
patrol strategy in this on this game
board when they execute randomized
patrols for several months and poachers
attack targets we get crime data from
this crime data we can learn something
about the adversaries decision making
because we are assuming now the
adversaries are not acting with perfect
rationality we're trying to learn their
decision- making model their bounded
rationality model which is then going to
feed into our calculation of a mixed
strategy and so this is quite different
from the earlier work on infrastructure
security because now we have attack data
which allows us to learn something about
our adversaries and improve our
decision- making in terms of calculating
randomized patrols so I'm going to now
outline some of the research challenges
and our Solutions this is as I said new
work work that's ongoing so there's lots
more to do I'll start by looking at the
bounded rationality models um and the
algorithms that need to be generated for
that and so obviously we are getting
data from the field and I'll show you
some results from that data but speed up
data collection we also have constructed
a poaching game so this is an online
game where um people play for real money
this is played on MK and this is a
forest area where we've divided up the
forest into grid cells grid cells with
higher levels of green are less Patrol
less frequently adversaries can attack
without the probability of high
probability of being captured red are
areas where they're patrolled more
frequently the number of animals number
of hippos in a cell is related to the
value of that cell we chose hippos
because they're non-charismatic species
so people will not feel as bad poaching
and people are acting as poachers and
the algorithm is acting as you know
generating the different patrolling
stratey IES here so people can go to
different locations um there's a s you
know success if they get if they're
successful uh they get a certain reward
if they fail they get a certain penalty
they can see the probability of success
and failure if they go to a location
they succeed they get real money if they
go to a location their snaring fails
they lose money and so we've been
playing these sorts of games with people
for many years now collecting lots of
data now normally if we assume a game
theoretic rational player what we would
assume is that everybody is calculating
expected utility and then um you know so
this is just the capture probability
multiplied by penalty plus the not
capture probability multiplied by reward
and everybody would go to one cell and
we'll find all attacks in that one cell
or maybe just maybe just around it but
what happens in reality is that the
attacks are spread all over and the
model that we found that better fits how
people are acting is this quantal
response model what this is a this is
stochastic Choice model cells with
higher expected utility people are more
likely to attack cells with lower
expected utility people are less likely
to attack but the probability is not
zero if you use this model of course
that leads to a a non-convex nonlinear
optimization problem um and you know
solving these Pro once you get past that
and come up with a Defender strategy so
we are assuming that the adversaries are
acting according to this quantal
response
model the Quant response
I guess have to read article on yeah so
I guess and there's a long history goes
back to loose and in 1960 and so forth
but I guess uh you know mcfaden got a
Nobel Prize for you know some of this
work so this is all sort of rooted now
it's sort of invaded Game Theory and
there's a lot more work on uh kind of
different Quantum response models and so
forth but this is I mean this is one
point of origin some people actually
site loose uh and and go back even more
to random utility models and so forth um
so if we assume that the adversary is
acting according to Quantum response and
generate our strategies according to
that and play against humans it turns
out that we perform better these are
just four of the games that we've played
on the y-axis is Defender expected
reward uh on the xais of you know four
different Games Lower is worse higher is
better if we assume adversaries are
acting according to perfect assuming
perfectly rational we get the blue bar
which is the worst performing bar
Epsilon rationality is green quantum
respons leads to Red so assuming that
the adversaries are acting according to
Quantum response leads to better
performance for the
defender we can do go on adversaries
Dynamic but you have to be fixed we have
to be fixed the adversaries then choose
a particular location to attack knowing
the probability of where we are
patrolling come back next day same can't
change so in this case it's a one-hot
game so in this case we are just playing
once and that's it um
in th's PhD thesis she figured out that
uh there's a better way in Improvement
or quantal response that's possible
which is subjective utility Quantum
response so we are looking at each T it
seems like we could model people as as
though they're looking at each Target
capture probability reward and penalty
as some sort of features of that Target
and then you take a weighted sum the
weights are learn from past attack data
and then use that subjective utility to
generate a sub utility Quantum response
model and in human subject experiments
and playing against humans assuming
they're playing subjective utility
Quantum response leads to better
performance but this is all lab data
more recently we got data from Uganda 17
years of data and this is showing a fit
of the model that we have to the data
from Uganda on poaching attacks these
are rooc curves and um the main thing we
want to know here is that going to this
corner is the is better as we know and
you can see that sqr which is shown in
blue is significantly better than
Quantum response and other models that
we could think of now th has been
working on improving the model go ahead
which is the actual data these are
pretty good the other ones so basically
we've learned from let's say past years
and then we are trying to predict for
next year so we may have you know so
this is like a from training we have
learned about uh be uh you know our
models weights and then on testing we
are testing you know predicting so gu if
you were to fit the data that you had
using the like either the quto response
or the sqr
response which one is a better fit so so
blue the blue is a better fit the more
you go towards here the better it is
that's basically people that are caught
verus get through right so in this model
the true positives are catching folks
right and so so we are we are trying to
predict poaching attacks and so get them
I mean
um I'm sorry you your question oh I was
just as interested to to to know um what
the do you use a basian model to get
this objective how how do you generate
this objective utility sorry St
probability on the way utility do I can
see like for example really Rich models
that use features like availability bias
like my cousin was caught in that region
and that really sticks in my mind it
makes it higher you imagine like people
amplify recen SE for example uh and
that's that's I'm going to there I'm I'm
going there I'm going there that's
wonderful that's Wonder so this is uh
this is and th is working with and this
is our you know partly our collaboration
with Lucas but we so this is assuming a
single adversary type meaning everybody
has the same weits this is Cap like Risk
covers risk loving like I'm for a bigger
reward I'm willing to take some risk
versus a very conservative culture that
is trying to minimize risk so so we
haven't yet gone there I mean what we
have done is taking all the animals to
be the same value right now just learn
the weights from the data you've been
caught for like 3 weeks in jail or
something right and so we've we've just
I mean there's a lot more to be done in
terms of all kind and there's all kinds
of features in the domain slope of the
land the vegetation cover all kinds of
things like that and what th is doing
right now to give away some of what
where she's going is well the
observations are not perfect so we
really need a we need to model
observational uncertainty so all of that
is yet to be done see I can imagine a
really rich sitation maybe it's the
topic already on on just um using using
the the basic standard quantal response
model mod and looking at in inducing the
the human probabilities based on sets of
features and like Notions like the
actual logs of what is a model of what
somebody has heard about the news about
where someone's caught for example and
did somebody's could you compute whether
somebody's family member was somebody
they would know on a social graph would
know about them being C grid cell x j
and actually showing how these you with
the actual landscape of the cognitive
assessments are versus the actual
probability which also have an influence
too because they say that well people if
they're ideal they would learn the
actual probabilities but the de to do
that they going to have their own model
of this things like recency be very
important I think is also so yeah so so
this this model is assuming that they
are observing what the guards are doing
perfectly whereas people are going to
have some kind of a local or bias
acknowledgement that that's true yeah
and if you ask them like you know what's
the if you actually could have cool to
get one of these poachers and show them
the Grid or show them the land and say
give you probability being caught in
these places and then post a news story
about like real real story person X was
caught you know running with a tiger you
know in this area it's like okay now we
assess and see how these these
the sense sense things you could sense
about things that people could see could
be used to to model people would think
so so you can see why we are so I mean
it's an important area and why we are so
excited about all the different ways in
which this can be extended so one way in
which we thought it could be extended is
by going from sqr to basian sqr where we
allow for uh different groups of people
to have different
weights a question I mean I assume this
as as uqr was basian what what do you
mean by non-asian versions of that I
mean in the sense that there is a single
adversary type uh in the sense that how
do you come up with with that estimate
of the weights from past attack data so
we look at let's say you may have you
know we have 17 years of data in
this she actually use past attack data
to induce a probability to to look at
the weights the weights and based on
those weights then we get the
probability of
attack I see so the weights are
basically weight to wait the
probability um based on what actually
what they did see yeah I like the basy
idea okay so so that's what we did okay
so that's what we did next uh so now we
said there's a heterogeneous population
of poachers we learn different groups of
weights and now we want to go from one
shot games to repeated games and we
right now we're playing this on Amazon
on mtk again and so our thought was sqr
is good uh clearly beat people in single
shot game basy and sqr must be even
better and so we played repeated games
this is not easy on MK so we have to
chase people so for every game uh 40
people we recruited and chased them by
sending many many emails please come
back play this game please come back
play this game so this is uh what we
call a longitudinal study in the sense
it's 35 weeks where we chased 40 people
to play this game again and again and
again and my student debarun sent 10,000
emails in the process to get people to
come back and play this game again this
is what it took and at the end of it so
we wanted to show that a learning sqr
model one where we learn would do
significantly better than a non-learning
model and so these are rounds of the
game on the xaxis defender expected
utility on the Y AIS lower is worse
higher is better Maxim is the most
simple strategy we could think of no
learning nothing
and what we found is that our sqr model
performed worse than maximin and basian
sqr performed far worse and never
recovered and so there's something So
eventually sqr can of learns and settles
and improves over maximin but round two
clearly it is much worse and so there's
something missing in the process and so
we were trying to understand why is it
in one shot games we were doing so well
and as soon as we went to repeated games
things started falling apart and what we
found out is uh that people will do sup
what we'll call superstitious learning
as it is known in the psychological
literature essentially there may be
something they may have made a really
good choice a great place to attack in
terms of expected utility they go there
by random chance this is random mice
patrolling they get caught then they say
well this was not a good place to attack
let me go somewhere else and they may
have made an error they may have gone to
a wrong place but by random chance they
succeeded they'll say well this is a
really great place let me come back here
again and so in a sense they get this
kind of reinforcement which we can model
by essentially increasing or decreasing
subjective utility from the last round
so we are now bumping up this subjective
utility based on whether they succeeded
or failed rather than where they
attacked which was what we had used in
the past so so now they so
so a a true basian subjective utility
would actually have models of this this
strange uh these strange biases you'd
actually put distinctions in about
things like recency and
superstitiousness this is what I mean by
basian like this want to have a rich
basian model of what people are doing
and it might be a very very deep model
that that gets into things like this
idea of availability and biased by
experience and I I'm surprised that
that's doing worse for Defender utility
so so I should say that our terminology
of basian sqr is basically you know
basian as in you know we have basian
games so we have adversary types and so
we are saying there's you know different
kinds of adversary types and so that's
what but we haven't I mean what this is
saying is that there's an additional
additional effect over and above that
simple characterization of types as
simply being characterized by different
weights for different populations or
something like that we need to have an
additional phenomenon that we had not
captured before how so where did the
weights come from so we learning from
data by basian you you me you mean um
you um don't marginalize all data to the
single episer type you actually allow
given experiences but it's still being
done coherently versus
this idea we'll call it um for now given
that you're calling that basian uh human
cognitive subject sqr yes and I always
basically refer to that as basian
approach so anyway you see you meant
probally sound with with separate groups
based on uh Keyhole views into this into
where things have happened right and on
it is like the overfitting problem in
machine you know you're trying to
represent some complex Phenomenon with
simple representations and when you over
fit to that then the performance gets
worse after some point I wonder it's
like that kind of that all I guess our I
mean one thing what we are saying is
that there's an additional phenomena
that we had not taken into account which
certainly is not in the behavioral Game
Theory literature as far as we are aware
uh to take this additional phenomenon
into account I mean obviously people are
getting reinforced I mean that we now
but this is saying this is embedded on
top of the quantal response model and
that once we do that then it improves
performance so in a sense we are saying
yes there is some truth to the quantal
response model everything is good so
that's the one where we take the sqr and
add this bumping up and down of
subjective utilities based on proportion
of people succeeded or that's I call but
interesting I what I meant by isation I
meant like that to understand the actual
foundations of the cognitive model based
on repeat exposures to evidence would be
a really rich beautiful piece of work so
so the sharp model which I mean it's an
acronym we love acronyms so so it's it's
it's not there's a more uh you know
spelled out name to it but in any any
event the point is that it is taking the
subjective utility model and saying well
we're going to increase and decrease it
based on the experiences people had
right so it be really nice to to um
featuri the space uh from the point of
view of a lot of observational features
recency of various events how many might
be might be
scal Notions of counts of experiences
and what would be cognitively salience
and build like a baset and see what
would happen even Beyond weights going
up and down but sounds listic right now
yes so so I just think it's really great
opportunity to make those black lines
even higher there
I some of it not all of it some of it is
in th's work that we're doing with Lucas
now but there's a lot more I completely
agree there's a lot more there's a big
big what's exciting about it is that we
you know I'm not sure what the
literature is like these days and
um Mo modern versions of probability
assessment with humans about like the
alite games we can play but you know for
for kind of a repeat game situation with
a rich static relatively static frame
like poaching in these grid cells be
really nice to see the model you can
display out with just lots of data and
how people believe by doing the
assessment we do this on tur too
probably so maybe we actually have data
we can actually play with you know from
the tur games and see if we can build
the baset that that that does compliment
SE yeah what you done and and um so let
me push ahead because uh I about this is
also is the you learn about people and
how they overreact with their bias are
to events in in the world um what uh our
most memorable know a lot of it would be
kind of like a basian approach to the
turis encoun literature and say we have
these distinctions now we're build a
model that predicts probabilities so now
I want to tell you something about Ki
this model sharp in our
experiments people's probability
perception we found is exact opposite of
How It's stated in prospect theory so we
are not sure what's going on completely
but what the data shows is that in their
in their model basically people overway
low probability and underway high
probability in our experiments is
flipped people underway low probability
so it's like point2 probability I don't
care I'm going in 6 oh that's a lot I'm
not going in could be um a couple things
right so um it could
be and this take a lot longer discussion
and and deep dive but it could be how
you're representing risk
aversion um and um you might have people
with a short timeline they're taking
risks they're not being risk neutral and
so that could explain some of those
Vedge effects um prospect theory gets
into also not just the B is handled but
it's in my mind more about the the
overweighting people get to utility and
underweighting with where loss where
losing utility is much more painful yes
yes on the scaler scale absolute scale
than gaining the same amount back so I
also wonder you know the game this game
is a lot more complex than most games
that psychologist work with in their exp
I know it's really rich that's why it's
exciting yeah it is it is Big it has a
lot of probabilities it is sequential so
there's coming back I wonder if people
are following some strategies to make
the problem simple in their minds kind
of cut off parts of the Stace space like
that probability is small I'm not going
to worry about it that probability is
large I'm going to focus there to kind
of make the problem complex and
manageable for them and if the problem
was simpler maybe this effect on
probabilities would be significantly
different and and I think this is very
interesting because you know the context
of how experiments were done in the past
versus this may I mean this is what our
psychology friends tell us that that
might be the source of the explanation
imagine following up on as you know sort
of ideas and having enough data to say
here's a rich new cognitive model about
how people deal with the bounded memory
and state space pruning and you can
actually by building a a structural
model generate humanik probabilities
given exposures this would be like a we
should like do this for a year just just
do this you great great you mi the game
make it simpler make it more complex
change of probability this way collect
data again and again we this is like the
kind of thing that like big Josh Tenon
bound
Jew kind of model human you B the
rationality of probability assessment
you could also play with how you present
information because you can say point
two but you can also do something like
the news report like while they play the
game on T you tell them someone just got
caught here right and it's not really a
high probability but they just it's very
avilable
idea so spatial reasoning uh I'll try to
walk through this somewhat more oh good
good good good that's that's the main
point that's main point so this is
Andrew lamu our collaborator he tried
this out in Uganda this pause system
which is generating patrols and he came
back and said you're your geography you
need to pay more attention to geography
because we're asking people to walk over
water because water bodies had merged
and we didn't know about this then we
started working with panthera and this
is uh you know part of Malaysia it's a
wonderful place they uh started
patrolling uh so this is um finding a
tiger footprint a poachers Camp along
the patrols but they also came back and
said paths are difficult to follow so
they are in Malaysia we are in La we
having Skype calls and they're saying
that the shortest distance between two
points is not a straight line and uh we
very confused by this so we went
Malaysia to see what was so special in
Malaysia we did an 8 Hour Patrol
ourselves in the forest and so this is
at the beginning of the patrol we're so
happy this is me Fay and my former yeah
former post. B uh 8 Hour Patrol ready
to and uh you can see at the end of the
8 hours uh completely gone and uh this
is uh you know so This Is Us in the in
the I guess it's not playing but but
anyway so this is just show was supposed
to show you patrolling us actually
patrolling but in the process we figured
out what was going wrong and Fay figured
out something very important and so if
you look at it uh in terms of a 3D view
uh on what was going on so it'll turn
now I guess it's a little bit dark here
but you can see here there are uh
mountains and uh so well you can't quite
see but there it's a very mountainous
region and so if you ask people to just
walk in straight L you're asking them to
go up and down and they they lose a lot
of energy so what we what faith figured
out is that in the forest inside
actually there's a hidden street map
that people are following they're
following Ridge lines they're following
water uh you know River beds and so this
hidden street map is what the patrollers
are actually following and we need to
grab that and work with that and so if
we look at it in terms of uh how this we
can now build a hierarchical game model
so there is is a grid structure but the
defender is actually not playing on the
grid they're playing along these Patrol
paths this street map which is made of
Ridge lines streams from which we get a
street map from which we generate actual
Patrol routes and uh so Defenders are
choosing paths on the patrol routes that
adversaries however are only looking at
individual grid cells and attacking on
grid cells adversaries action is local
they're not try they're not trying to
figure out which Patrol route you're
taking what what problem they're saying
in my area of Interest how frequently do
you come and I'm going to go based on
that choose my action and so this is
kind of a a hierarchical model that
we've built and used in in pause a
little bit here Ken sure so I'm
surprised
that that the attacker poer actions
wouldn't also be guided by efficiencies
of access the same way that Defender
patroller is they should be so this is a
computational convenience right now for
us meaning that uh cuz if we also so
model the attacker as having this it
just basically yeah then it just it's
now we are talking about path
intersection and so forth and it I mean
it's it's already I was just going to
tell uh tell you that this next part
which is handling of uncertainty shows
you some of the complexities which is
part of th thesis even with this model
that we have you used the convenience of
the grid cell for the attacker you could
take the the probability Mass of what
they're going to do and and spread it
over the actual paths right that's
possibility that way you would do the
inference and then at least concentrate
the probability on the paths and so so
that's that's that's good that's good
that's good
so I have uh 15 minutes let me uh walk
through some of this
and I would this is our lunch right we
keep on going I I would love for this to
continue so so we can't we have to see
everything you intended at least so
um one of the challenges is that we
don't have exact information of where
the animals are there's uncertainty
which means that the payoffs have to be
modeled with uncertainty one way to
model this uncertainty is interval
uncertainty there may be there may be
other ways too but here for example
we're saying that the adversary's payoff
here is between Min -4 and min-2 we
don't know exactly what it is now to
solve these problems one approach is a
behavioral Minimax regret and Minimax
regret is a technique in AI some of you
may know very well I'm just going to
walk you through how this would work and
notionally explain how the algorithm
works
so the regret of a particular strategy X
can be computed in this fashion we take
a sample of the game so we're just
looking at one sample of the
payoff X is the defender strategy this Q
represents adversary's response because
they are playing with Quantum response
so now we get a Defender expected
utility of minus of5 so we've played a
strategy the adversary has responded we
got a Defender expected utility the
regret of this strategy X is if we had
played the optimal strategy xstar we
would have actually gotten a Defender
expected utility of2 so our regret here
is 7 because we got minus of5 and we
should have gotten point2 so that's the
regret of this strategy X for this
payoff
instance now if we were to play this
strategy X on another game instance
which is shown here the same strategy
but on another game instance from the
same interval uncertainty that we had it
turns out that the regret has gone up to
1.2 instead of 7 because here the
optimal strategy would have the defender
strategies would have given us the
utility of Point minus of
.9 so going over all possible instances
over all all of the entire interval we
if we can find that one instance that
would give us the maximum regret that's
what we would get as the maximum regret
of playing the strategy X over all
possible game instances so we want to
find that one strategy X which minimizes
our maximum regret over all possible
game instances and so that's what we are
after we're trying to come up with this
uh solve this optimization problem we
are trying to minimize our
regret where X and R are decision
variables this is the utility loss to
the defend uh Defender for playing a
strategy X over all possible payoffs
that could be sample and the only
problem here is we could solve this
except that there's infinite number of
constraints because all POS is in you
know the space is continuous so how do
we solve these uh problems so one way to
do this this is by iterative constraint
generation so the idea here is uh we
start with the master problem which is
going to solve our Minimax regret for
some sampled payoff so it's going to
find that one strategy X which is
minimizing maximum regret for some let's
say three sample payoffs and it finds
this optimal strategy and using that now
we find an upper bound which is that
payoff which gives us the highest regret
given this optimal strategy we Fe that
back into the master and so now we've
kind of created a lower bound and an
upper bound and we can keep iterating
until the lower bound and upper bound
collapse and we get the optimal the one
that minimizes our maximum regret in
pictures um so we start with the payoff
sample we get an optimal strategy now it
turns out that this payoff maximizes our
regret given that strategy so now we
have these two instances we generate
this optimal pay this optimal strategy
this is our lower bound but now given
this as our strategy we can generate a
pay of that maximize our regret again so
this is an upper bound now we generate a
strategy which generates a lower bound
to that and so we keep iterating in this
fashion until we converge and there can
be no more improvements and that's our
Minimax regret now
unfortunately what assum the Assumption
here is that we have only two rows two
Defender strategies so this works as
long as the number of Defender
strategies is small if the number of
Defender strategies becomes very very
large because there's many many possible
roots in the forest we need to embed
this iterative process in a bigger
iterative process and so this Arrow
algorithm which is the behavior Minimax
regret is now embedded in another
process where incrementally adding new
Roots so you generate a few Roots you
run this Minimax regret then you add
more Roots you generate Minimax regret
and you keep keep doing it until the
whole process converges and so it's sort
of this double kind of iteration of
convergence that leads to Optimus so
it's it's sort of so initially it'll
start with just two Roots do Minimax
regret then add one more roote do
Minimax regret until there can be no
more Improvement in the process so
that's you assuming that if someone's on
Route in a CR cell they could inspect
and also scare off a poacher anywhere in
the Square we are assuming that they
they have to cover some fraction of the
but other than that yes that's what
we're assuming exactly and so this is
pause this is what we have built as the
system and we've handed over to to
Malaysia uh to uh so pause has
hierarchical modeling cutting planes
Minimax regret uh there's more um so Fe
wrote this paper that said well we can
do more with planning and learning to
kind of deceive attackers and so forth
but this is not in the implemented
system syst it's in regular use in the
sense that patrols are going out by
panthera these are some pictures from
those
patrols and this is um showing you now
uh one Patrol that was planned and how
closely it was followed showing that
they are able to follow these Patrol
routes this is uh basic information of
the patrol average strip length uh
number of patrollers number of hours per
day that they travel these are some
pictures from the patrols they found uh
up P your scan there and this is say you
know we're trying to compare how well
these patrols are performing there's not
a perfect comparison but if you look at
how many animal signs per uh kilometer
we finding how many human signs per
kilometer we so this is our patrols blue
and red green is what they were previous
patrols but these are not exactly for
the same purpose they were all trying to
do a tiger survey so maybe animal signs
per kilometer found is a more reasonable
comparison this may not be this is um
footprint of a tiger a footprint of
something this where animals have to be
walking around and human science are
assumed poachers making marks poachers
camps you know they leave lighteners
behind they leave shoes behind and why
is animal science important because Poes
will be will go there eventually and
also part of it part of the input that
they're optimizing over is a
distribution model of an animal distrib
ution model that's built off of animal
well certainly the animal ution models
cross with the ease of access should be
in the probability uh ADV serious
probability model you think I think that
they they learn about animal
availability also that so that is indeed
the the sqr has a weight given to animal
density per grid cell so that's where
that's yeah so one of the things that's
coming in here that will eventually be
coming in here are things like
GPS tracks of animals in the park right
and the thing that's interesting is like
these street maps are kind of a proxy
for animal movement patterns as well but
not a perfect proxy and and so there's
going to be there's an animal street map
and there's a human street map and where
those two things intersect are where
poachers set snares basically um so so
one of the things that I've been
thinking about is saying okay well we
have
uncertainty in in the species
distribution model that animals have I
mean there's uncertainty of the mental
model that poachers and Rangers have
about the true underlying distribution
of animals but that model we have
uncertainty about so we can ask the
question of saying well we have a
potential maximum reward of catching
poachers now based off a animal
distribution map with current
uncertainty and if we take a little bit
off of that expected return on poaching
to collect better data on animal signs
that will increase that observation map
then five steps down maybe we'll be
doing better than we would five steps
down if we just went for current maximiz
anti- poaching efforts right and so
that's this kind of short-term versus
longterm um data versus data versus um
observ poaching observation so that's
interesting so last couple of slides
what we are hoping for is collaboration
with panthera to go to many different
sites that they're active in
and this is under active uh negotiation
and discussion with them so we will see
how that goes and uh we have also
started working with WWF so this is a
workshop in Indonesia that th went to so
this is Nicole one of members of our
group and this a workshop with the
Rangers and so forth WCS WWF and so on
in Indonesia there's a pause Workshop so
Nicole got a sign everybody got a pause
certificate for attending the workshop
and as part of the workshop T and Nicole
went on elephant rides and I mean this
is because they're trying to protect
elephants but this is another
collaboration that's budding that's
moving forward and we hope also to
collaborate with ww after deploying
Indonesia in the near
future and so that's uh that's it I
guess uh to summarize uh we're moving
from infrastructure security games which
is what we were doing in the past to
Green security this opens up a whole
whole new set of research challenges
because from single short games we are
going to repeated games there's large
amounts of repeated attacks which gives
us data which allows us to build models
of human behavior so this is exciting
because we have from behavioral Game
Theory some models but here now we have
real data from poaching from the field
and all of the insights from
conservation biology and so forth can
now be brought in so there's a very
interesting intersection of conservation
criminology and computation that's
possible here and modeling attacker
bounded rationality the fact that they
have limited surveillance they have
limited planning all kinds of things
like that are important and planning uh
you know Forest paths and all kinds of
uh and we we already discussed many many
other research challenges here and
so from our perspective uh even though
there are Global efforts in security
games it's just the beginning there are
many applications from testing in muks
to audit games to Software
testing uh modeling diseases and
combating diseases that people are
working on we are very thrilled with
seeing security games being applied in
all these different directions we're
working uh with the TSA on a newer
project uh for improving airport
screening and so I end want to end by
thanking our sponsors our create
Homeland Security Center Army research
office TSA and the US Coast Guard so
thank
you
go ahead in this suring St especially in
the forest Is it feasible to have drones
it is the the thing is though I mean
Lucas may have far more information
about drones what I heard in Uganda in
Malaysia and so forth is that there just
is not the infrastructure to support
drones um but Lucas may have far more
information yeah it depends I mean a lot
of it is like they're already flying a
lot of these missions in Savannah
systems where drones make sense because
you can actually see stuff a lot of
things like in Malaysia you're looking
down at a green canopy and there's not
much to see um there's a there's a lot
of problems with drones hopefully that
some of which we might solve over the
next couple years but there's a lot of
problems with drones and deploying them
in real world situations with people who
aren't drone experts and Engineers the
there's a guy I mean you guys maybe you
probably know him um Tom snitch at
Maryland who's been in the news a lot
for um working with um uh the lindenburg
foundation for deploying these kinds of
optimal predictive patrols for drone
routing um but again they work in
basically there's like a van like
follows this drone you know I mean it's
pretty cloy still um
anyway so what are your thoughts you
know in any of these areas you looked at
you could always invest more in X Y or Z
more people increasing the number of
controls increasing the number of boates
a new a new sensor like a drone and you
could turn you this is really nice
opportunity um to turn a prank given
your best method you have available and
to stick in a new sensor and return the
crank with probability distribution of
what you'd see if you if you use that
new sensor and then compute the value of
adding that new sensor or policy or boat
or patrols change we call this like
maybe value of enhanced policy and
here's the dollar value and here's what
my crank with my methods as based level
being looked at in times with tell us so
you think that would be a really nice
way to do provide guidance to to a
agencies right and we are doing some of
that with AVG and so forth in Madagascar
is with our colleagues in Michigan State
which is uh given the fixed number of
dollars what's the best you can buy in
terms of equipment well that's one thing
then you say okay if I had if I had n
more dollars I say inally how much more
can you get so that's the cool thing is
you have the the base apparatus for
doing the the each Baseline and so you
give a value information or value
sensing on top of the current policy
that's a that's a very fun Point we'd be
very fun to try that out yes I agree I
agree with
that okay
good does the approaches just
generalized to reason about so we worked
we worked with a conservation drone
company you know remember the name of it
in the Netherlands for a while to
generate drone routes for them for
preference elicitation you know where
would you fly in order to reduce
uncertainty in the forest the most
things like that and so we were really
hoping for that collaboration to move
forward but
uh it's it's tough I mean it just seems
like the infrastructure in many of these
countries is just not there so we heard
in some places people say we're not
ready you know for for such things so it
could be maybe it's a couple of years I
don't know how many more years but right
now it's not there yet yes it's just
like there's cultural sensitivities
obviously and then there's topography
and vegetation so like Nepal just banned
the use of drones full
style um for privacy
issues
yeah I mean they take the welfare of
their animals and nature very seriously
they don't want anything flying around
just in time to to not prevent their use
for helping with the earthquake open
there yeah yeah exactly yeah so yeah so
that's there's the other side of the
problem that the poers can use the
drones as well yeah so I mean that's
yeah I mean it's the but there's there's
the Drone issue in conservation is
something that you know we've been
interested in for a long time it's kind
of blowing up at the moment um but the
the gap between reality and hype is
still significant I think
what you know this kind of work is
coming this way drones are maturing over
here and probably in a couple years
there will be
sustained um sustained um flights in you
know certain national parks in South
Africa for instance daily running
optimized patrols those sorts of things
I think we're within one to two years of
that but then large deployments is going
to be and there there I mean there's no
doubt so many interesting questions that
those you know things open up and so
lots of things to think about there too
well like Vulcan Paul Allen's
organization they have this great
African elephant census that they're
basically trying to count all the
elephants in Africa by flying missions
in Mann aircraft over the continent
right I mean of course they have
sampling strategies for trying to infer
but um obviously they're desperately
interested in how to do this without
actually putting people in the air
everything from image recognition of
elephants on the ground to
Longs um long flight times and things
like that but also being able to do
build out those routes based off of um
not necessary well I mean encounter
probabilities basically they want be
able to apply um so there's people
driving the supp it it's
just
brutal okay it's past 12 um thank thank
you thank you for coming thank you for a
very interesting set of questions thank
you